"Escribe 18% como decimal y como fracción
simplificada", así que hagámoslo primero como
decimal. Entonces 18% es lo mismo que 18 por cada
100, pero lo escribimos como 18%. Ciento significa
lo mismo que 100, entonces esto significa
literalmente 18 por cada 100. Dije primero
que haríamos el decimal, pero podemos comenzar
escribiendo la fracción: 18 por cada 100 como
una fracción significa literalmente 18/100.
Estamos haciendo primero la fracción, esto
literalmente significa 18/100 o 18 centésimas. A
partir de esto podemos ir directamente a un número
decimal o podemos escribir esta fracción como
fracción simplificada. Primero hagamos el decimal,
porque eso es en realidad lo que dije que haríamos
primero. Esto es lo mismo que 18 centésimas,
y sabemos cómo escribir eso en forma decimal
es: 0.18. Podemos ver esto como 1 décima y 8
centésimas, que es lo mismo que 10 centésimas
y 8 centésimas, que son 18 centésimas,
de modo que esto está escrito en forma decimal. Y
si lo escribimos como una fracción simplificada,
necesitamos ver si hay un factor común para 18 y
100. Ambos son números pares, así que sabemos que
ambos son divisibles entre 2, así que dividamos
el numerador y el denominador entre 2. Entonces
tenemos 18 ÷ 2 /100 ÷ 2, y el resultado de 18 ÷ 2
es 9, 100 ÷ 2 es 50, y no creo que estos números
compartan factores comunes: 50 no es divisible
entre 3, 9 sólo es divisible entre 3, 1 y 9,
entonces esta es la fracción simplificada.
Así que tenemos que 18% es lo mismo que 0.18,
que es lo mismo en su forma simplificada que
9/50. Ahora pasamos por mucha dificultad para
mostrar que esto realmente viene de la expresión
por ciento por cada 100, pero si alguna vez
tuvieran un problema como este, la forma rápida
de resolverlo es decir inmediatamente: "Bien,
si tengo 18%, o cualquier cosa que tengamos antes
del porcentaje, lo que sea, será igual a eso -en
este caso 18- sobre 100". Y en otra forma de
pensar en esto podríamos verlo como 18.0%,
18.0%, acabo de agregar un 0 al final para
que vean el punto decimal. Pero si queremos
expresar esto como un decimal, sin el signo de
porcentaje, simplemente tenemos que mover el
punto decimal dos posiciones a la izquierda, de
modo que si movemos el punto decimal dos espacios
a la izquierda -uno, dos- esto se convierte en
0.18. Entonces podríamos decir inmediatamente
que 18% como una fracción es 18 /100, cuando lo
escribimos en forma simplificada es igual a 9/50;
pero también deberíamos ver que 18/100 -ya lo
dijimos antes- es exactamente lo mismo que 18
centésimas o 0.18. Espero que con esto hayas
hecho algunas conexiones y no te confundas.